yo wassup your boy can't sign I beat
Logan Pole and this is that story I got
started on YouTube around 2010-11 I
started doing gaming videos just playing
Fifa pool of duty so the whole boxing
thing started from Joella actually he
was the guy who called me on my bluff I
told him I'll fight the winner of him
and his friend he beat his friend and
then he came to me I told him I wasn't
really on it and he made videos calling
me a puppy this that so we had a press
conference it got heated yeah me and
Joelle had a fight and I beat him so I
called out the poor brothers IVA Jake or
Logan any of the poles at first they
tried to get great poll involved great
pool is their dad we hang or funny old
man sir Logan was the only guy properly
down so me and him went at it
I was with Logan Paul I respect what
he's done on YouTube platform where are
a lot of good videos you know he works
hard but I don't respect him as a person
no right man would ever record someone
who has died and put on the internet and
show it to all his millions of fans I
mean talk about having yes men around
you like doesn't at no point did he'd
think maybe this is too much or maybe
this is ridiculous he was just thinking
this can get views this is gonna get
attention I thought I was actually
disgusting so you know at the time when
I called him out
I was definitely doing him a favor
because you know the whole suicide
forest thing was happening and him
tasting a dead rat as well you know he
just had a lot of bad press and I think
he definitely wanted to try and take
attention away from that - yeah I
essentially you know saved his career by
calling him out we got the contract so I
mean loving how we had a feed back and
forth it's quite mental much history and
it was the place we were flying sold out
and we went at it and after six rounds
it was at all I didn't think it was a
draw if I'm being honest I thought I
might just scraped it but you know I
definitely warranted
we managed to show like it was a close
fight he did well for someone who only
books for a couple of months yeah that's
why it was beautiful that the rematch
came the next year little to this one
you know we were still somewhat
interacting with each other by it so
it's just like public like I'd never
message him in privately I think he
tried messaging me privately but I
changed my number he had my old number
so it was funny I have no idea why he
sent me by started dealing me on
Instagram instead yeah I thought he was
just saying some stupid stupid stuff so
with the press conference I didn't want
to just do the exact same thing I did
all Shane just clown him and I knew you
to expect that so I wanted to be a
little more serious this time and I
wasn't gonna accept a draw he was a
complete opposite to how it was last
year loud is all over the place he's
bouncing around he wasn't serious at all
yeah there's a huge job supposition
between me and him for sure I think the
only time I got nervous it was the day
of the fight you know I was trying to
take my mind off things I was playing
call of duty triangle legends you know
storms my girlfriend
you know I chilled with the boys I was
training with trying to do everything to
take my mind off the fight Logan Paul
was the favorite everyone was rooting
for Logan pool and yeah Justin Bieber
was just praying to make sure looking
for one when in the dressing room to you
know pray with him again and do this in
that yeah it was crazy
yeah let's yeah I got nervous energy all
the way till the dressing room warmed up
a bit I'm still nervous and I was just
like oh this sucks
so I decided like I need to switch
something up so I just took a nap
except for like 20 minutes because we
had a bit of time I seen I woke up all
the nurses went I just felt calm and
ready and focused yeah I not talked a
lot
yeah as soon as I entered I rang and
just looked at Logan was crazy like the
whole time before before the fight he
was staring at me you know making jokes
doing this and that and as soon as us in
the ring with him he just couldn't look
at me he was looking on the floor he's
looking to the side
he just looked like he didn't want to be
there and yeah I was you know I was I
felt like a stallion man I stamping on
the ground III was just Bo I didn't look
at anyone else but him as crazy I felt
like a killer it's crazy yeah I was
ready man I was ready
yeah round 1 I came in and I was just I
did my thing you know jab to the body
jab to the body cuz I knew his head was
always gonna do this I knew his head
wasn't gonna be there I was first time I
you know tasted 10 ounce to the head and
it's actually called like when he hit me
I was like I was saying so bad I was
like I can deal with this cuz you know I
know I didn't really put his whole way
into his shot because he was just afraid
of me coming at him and you know
countering so it was quite 10224 with
his short round - yeah he tried to come
in with a few shots of his own and then
I'll just counter again and then he
would stay on the outside just you know
constantly moving running for me just
running around he didn't want to get
touched
round 3 uh you know I start to put
pressure on and uh you know I him with a
shot that knocked him down and reached
encounters or not down he's he said it
was just a slip weight and we all saw
the replay and it wasn't
but uh yeah he was a clinching my legs
which is funny yeah that was pretty much
again my round I was all over him and he
just wasn't on it
so round four just yeah you struggling
to deal with me and then he got very
good Sean hit me with the uppercut which
I didn't drop me but he definitely
stunned me but I think he got excited I
was able to actually hit me with a big
shot to the point where he held my head
down and hit me with a legal shot and
then hit me twice when I was going down
obviously he's like oh I should go
warning for that but you don't really
need a warning for something so illegal
it's kind of crazy like I was able to
just stand up instantly
I don't even know how going to the ref I
am in the back in the head and that's
why I love linkies you get hit in the
back and hedge your banishes toes man
referee beside you got five minutes to
rest I was thinking if I take five
minutes that's him resting for five
minutes
and you know I didn't want to give Logan
that much time so I was just looking I
was counting outside I'm just myself one
minute one is calm in previous fights
that's something like that has happened
they'll just get cooled off we'll just
tape the DQ I felt like I didn't want to
win like that for hours and injustice
you know got back up dusted myself off
took a minute break and then we went
back at it round five yeah I say that's
definitely his round I was sitting I was
still a bit face you know he got more
shots off how I'm gonna take this round
off and just take my time take it easy
make sure I didn't get hit with another
big shot again yeah so six that's when I
saw this is it I'm good I'm ready let's
go and I start going ham again yeah I
was just you know fine hey me
trying to put everything into it and
yeah he was just again running like no
hit run over him run and I was just
constantly trying again is growing so
big shot obviously I was in America I
was in his home country singing like the
judges were probably gonna be in his
favor but yeah so when I first had the
first judge and he and he gave it to
Logan outside but anyway yo second judge
he gave it to me I saw I this is this is
big and then obviously with the third
one when Michael waffle was just like
from the United as I was later you know
holding old in the tone little weighing
and when he said Kingdom BAM when
homicide let's go the judges they did
what they were meant to do like yeah
they were watching the white fight it is
you got Justin Bieber was just when he
lost I think at that point he became an
atheist
I never seen Logan's face at the end oh
man pure just celebrate my team yeah man
and then we went one oak against silver
with everyone nuts
we were saying if I want to fight Jay
Paul obviously I'm like you should go
fight Gib who's a friend of mine
everyone wants to see it and then if if
he beats Gib then I'll give Jake Paul a
chance and we'll go at it Oh to go to
arena
big boy thinks it's crazy let's go after
the fight my song down like that and
it's just on absolute numbers 20 plus
million streams and Spotify millions of
streams and other music dinner rounds
it's all over radio like it's literally
the most successful song I've
ever done and this year has been
incredible for me from releasing an
album with my friend Randall going on
tour training for this fight being local
pool and then putting out something
single yeah it's it's been a crazy year
and I'm excited for next year make sure
it's gonna be unreal yeah for this year
I think right now I definitely a holiday
[Music]